pick up we're taking a whole pot now I'd
like to present the talent of James Caan
and the exciting Raquel Welch two
Biggie's here to present here to present
the award for the best documentary
feature two really nice people James
Caan and Raquel well
the nominees for the best achievement
and documentary short subjects are
background
Carmen Divino producer children at work
Luis Marcus producer Christos Valley
curtain Albert and David Mosely's
producer for stones pecan omitsu
producers credits and controversy
Princeton a search for answers Julianne
training and wit else a junior producers
down below please the winner is a search
for answers Julianne Creighton and
DeWitt else a junior
I'd always wondered why people had
difficulty when they got up here in this
position now I know thank you very much
this is the best seat in the house thank
you very much
because documentary features are not
always shown on a regular basis in movie
theaters
we the Academy feel you should know more
about what this year's nominees have to
offer in the way of outstanding I was
never real good at reading creativity
and filmmakers Threepenny streak
usually they're not even shown during
this presentation but they're so
versatile and amazing and content it
wouldn't be fair just to mention the
title some things have to be seen to be
appreciated the nominees for best
achievement in featured documentation
are always a new beginning d the dell
producing battle of berlin
vingt bonzer Mergen producer the great
American cowboy Keith Merrill producer
journey to the Outer Limits
Alex glass off producer walls of fire
Gertrude Ross Marx and Edmund s penny
producers like the way you do it the
winner is the great American cowboy
to all my friends to whom I've already
recited this speech try to remember it
because I can't to the Academy thank you
very much to all of those who gave so
much to make this film a possibility
thank you the three very special people
to my mom who teach who taught me to
believe in God and uncompromising
principle and to my dad who taught me to
believe in myself and to my best friend
my wife who taught me to live by what
they taught me thank you very much